[Musik]
das regime von nordkorea ist ja ein
mysterium also ein stück weit das heißt
machen aber viele geheimnisse aus ihren
politischen entscheidungen
tims vater ist auch mal mit dem zug
gekommen der hatte wohl angst vorm
fliegen und auch angst vor anschlägen
bei seinem sohn ist das etwas anders der
fliegt im land also in nordkorea selbst
regelmäßig mit dem flugzeug
dass er jetzt mit dem zug kommt der
grund bleibt spekulation der grund
könnte aber sein dass auch er angst vor
anschlägen hat denn außerhalb seiner
eigenen landesgrenzen kann er natürlich
die sicherheit nicht so kontrollieren
wie es im inneren des landes ist es ist
so dass die staatsbesuche eigentlich nie
angekündigt werden sondern nachhinein
bestätigt werden das war schon mal kims
vater kim jong il so der hat seinen
letzten staatsbesuche kurz vor seinem
tod gemacht nach china und nach sibirien
nach russland hier scheint das ist jetzt
auf jeden fall ein arzt pädagogische
maßnahme
das verhältnis zwischen china und
nordkorea ist sehr schlecht geworden in
letzter zeit und nordkorea leidet stark
unter den sanktionen die china mit trägt
das heißt das war jetzt der bagger seite
gewünscht die beziehungen wieder zu
verbessern
und eben auch für china die möglichkeit
wieder teil des spiels zu werden
das chinesische fernsehen hat die die
bilder des staatsbesuchs übertragen bei
ihrem staatlichen senders cctv
und es ist natürlich immer eine auswahl
die gesteuert ist die soll in dem fall
zeigen hier kommt ja wie soll man sagen
der der kleine bruder aus nordkorea zum
rapport rüber und holt sich so die
bilder holt sich halt auch ein stück
weit die anweisungen aus peking wo jeden
ihr buch zum beispiel sieht man das
daran dass kim jong un wenn der
chinesische staatspräsident spricht sich
notizen macht dass er überhaupt nach
peking kommt und etwa nicht andersrum
welche liebe staatspräsident nach
nordkorea fährt ist auch ein zeichen
also das ist vor allem ein signal das
kind ging um unterschiedliche stadt wird
an die eigene bevölkerung in china und
an dem weltbevölkerung zeigen wollen
achtung wir stellen das alte verhältnis
kräfteverhältnis wieder her
[Musik]